i
[Música]
ah
la amazonía brasileña alberga la
extensión de bosques tropicales
lluviosos más grande del mundo sin
embargo este ecosistema tan importante
para la regulación del clima de las
lluvias está amenazado en los últimos
meses brasil ha registrado los peores
datos de deforestación de la última
década sólo en el pasado mes de mayo
pues dejó restando una área del tamaño
de la ciudad de río de janeiro además la
actividad ilegal de los buscadores de
oro también amenaza esta región de
bosques tropicales que en brasil se
divide entre 8 estados federados
finalmente los incendios son otro
peligro para esta región en los últimos
años nos hemos visto cada vez más
fuertes son casi siempre dolosos fruto
de la actividad humana que en muchos
casos busca abrir pastos para la
ganadería
[Música]
después de brasil bolivia es el segundo
país de la región que más bosques ha
perdido durante 2019 y 2020 producto de
los incendios forestales el país ha
perdido un total de 8 millones de
hectáreas durante estos años en parte
por la ampliación de la frontera
agrícola atribuible a las quemas
provocadas por los grandes agricultores
y también por los pequeños productores
que buscan ampliar sus terrenos de
cultivo los incendios han provocado
grandes pérdidas de biodiversidad que
según los especialistas tardarán décadas
en ser recuperadas esta situación
contrasta con lo que ocurría hace diez
años cuando bolivia era uno de los
países destacados en el manejo de sus
bosques y la protección de su
biodiversidad
[Música]
colombia es un país de bosques
tropicales según el ministerio de medio
ambiente estos ocupan cerca del 60% de
todo su territorio estos ecosistemas
regulan el clima el ciclo del agua la
concentración de dióxido de carbono y
proveen medicinas y recursos naturales
además son el hábitat de millones de
especies en colombia uno de los más
afectados es el bosque seco tropical del
cual se estima que tan sólo queda un 8%
la agricultura la urbanización y la tala
son los principales motivos de su casi
total degradación se estima que entre
1990 y el año 2010 los bosques
tropicales perdieron más de 300.000
hectáreas por año y fue la amazonía la
región más afectada naciones unidas-
llama a este 22 de junio en el día
internacional por la protección de estos
ecosistemas a una urgente acción humana
para reforestar
[Música]